i don't really i don't really insult
women and stuff like that i think it's a
bit mad i can't argue with gail then
it's like i feel like if i'm doing that
then i've got next thing i've got to be
on rupaul's drag race brother
forget me like it's going to be a bit
man i can't be arguing
big man tenure is castillo first aka the
main event aka the sniper bat shout out
to your baby now big man senior we live
in a world full of clout chasers rap and
i'm sick of it why can't a real g let me
find some real love brown you could get
nosebleeds when you get the wrong naan
bread how this is gonna work is i'm
actually gonna slap money in front of
these galbraiths 1 000 for my eternal
love and i'm gonna try and find out if
the girl that might hear for the money
and clown or they're there for real love
bruh big man thing this is cloud chasers
so my name is katarina and i am an
actress and stand-up comedian i'm here
for love definitely i mean i haven't
dated in quite a long time so
yeah definitely looking to meet someone
and see how it goes my perfect man has
to be funny because i do stand-up comedy
so they have to they have to have great
humor obviously
um
i would say passionate driven um
and just loyal and respectful like
respectful of my time and
yeah fun to be around i do love more
important definitely when it comes to a
relationship obviously when it comes to
my work money is very important but love
for sure would you ever be with a broker
i would i would be with someone who's
broke because you know i'm i'm an
independent woman i like to earn my own
money so i don't want to be relying on
someone to take care of me and you know
do stuff with me on the first date i
will always get my purse out because i
think it's just the polite thing to do
and it just shows that you have manners
and that you're a polite person
however
sometimes when i'm sat there i feel like
my inner feminist is just like leaving
my body and it's like i'm waiting for
them to jump in and say don't worry babe
i've got this
but i will always offer because i think
it's polite
thank you thank you i'm trying
to try and
yeah yeah proper tings what like real
rabbit fair yeah yeah from zara and that
you look nice where are you from thank
you um i'm from heart for sure halfway
yeah nice nice night do you know like
stevenage hatfield yeah i had a few
things up there like around here in
there
yeah yeah yeah yeah so like i know about
them places
you know you know that way yeah but what
are you saying before you start here
do you like black guys do i like black
guys love black guys
you know what you know i really like
okay this this is my idris elba
oh lovely dress elba in luffa have you
watched luffa yeah i don't look like
that though you don't know don't look
like you're dressing yeah but i'm just
saying he's really hard
with black guys yeah um what do you
think what did your parents think about
that no my parents they're not they're
not like racist or anything like that so
they wouldn't mind me the main event
they wouldn't mind that they wouldn't
mind if you're black or white yeah black
mixed race yeah they wouldn't they
wouldn't mind it's not at all i like
that i like that i'm greek anyway i'm
half greek
yeah i'm half greek separate half
english exotic things i like that
exactly
exotic things you get me i like that
obviously you know i'm looking for love
yeah yeah i mean i'm looking for a
serious thing trying to settle down in
that you get me yeah what'd you think
about six on the first date i personally
wouldn't have sex on the first date but
if a woman decided to have sex on a
first date i wouldn't like judge them
for it because i don't know sometimes
you just get really horny and it happens
it just it just happens right it just
happens again we've got cheers to that
it just it just happens you get it
i love that i try not to have sex on the
first date just because if i'm serious
about someone i sort of want to you know
see how it goes and then you've got yeah
and then you've got something to look
forward to as well yeah you're trying to
protect the gift in that you're getting
it well yeah just kind of see what see
what happens yeah now i feel you can't
be giving out the naan bread in that to
everybody you get me everybody deserves
the naan bread you get me you've got
you've got to pay for that oh yeah
exactly not everyone deserves it no no
no no no so i gotta ask you this as well
though my dm's is a mad team
have you got a lot of diamonds my dms is
a matching girl from north london south
east west beginning yeah chester
birmingham all of that what's the worst
dm like you've ever had from a girl like
the worst one like what's the most
shocking bin like i've had like yeah
message me that non-bread in that but
the worst one
messaged me i thought i saw the back off
the back off was looking mad yeah i was
like yo just turn around it was a dead
rev oh my god
no word of a lie oh my god bull bags and
all of that did you
the man was feeling a bit saucy that day
he thought you know let me show man my
ball bags and actually it's his choice
you get me gotta respect the choice
although i don't think i've never sent
like a [ __ ] pick never someone no i
don't really know i've sent a new like a
full-on like a full nude but not just of
my of my [ __ ] no who was it that you
sent in the new to oh to a boyfriend
can you trust him did you trust him yeah
yeah because you never know your folk
would be all up in czechoslovakian right
now you would never know i'm not like
well i wouldn't want to be along like
sites or something
yeah speaking of wisdom have you ever
made a sex tape i made a sex tape
i like to watch math
with a boyfriend i've made a sex tape
yeah with a boyfriend but not with like
a random person no but the boyfriend
though so the thing is i've done that
off a random person or some
next thing i meant on a rave in it and
then was it awkward went back to well we
went back to our yard and was getting
into the thing and that bridge and
started filming me i thought that was a
bit mad that is
a bit mad he's filming me in the
background in that you get me and it was
a bit it was yeah yeah it sounds like a
full-on porno yeah it's a bit mad i feel
like i can i get it anywhere if i want
to watch it is that often i feel like i
want to tell the feds about that you
know it's a bit mad like i'll never
become president now because this is mad
incriminating information like that you
get me man weren't really prepared for
that she just caught me off guard
yeah i'd be quite shocked by that i
think it's like consent as well like
you've got a consensus you've got to
respect consent you get me well you do
you can't just you can't just be
whipping out your phone and like filming
someone having sex
but that's what i wanted to ask you
though so are you a jealous person
though i'm very secure in myself however
i don't know say say we're here we're
here having this date right and say a
girl who you used to i don't know hook
up with comes up to you is like hugging
you and you're like oh my god i'm so
happy to see you i would be sitting here
getting a little bit jealous yeah and
then when she turned around too and i
was like are you looking at your sled
bevel don't watch me i'm gonna call her
a slap no but what if she said that to
you what are you gonna do you're gonna
ah what are you gonna do you're gonna
bust her up oh yeah a hundred percent
yeah what's your move then what's your
what's your move that you're gonna do
that's my name yeah like when she says
like yo why are you watching me let's
get all black are you watching me and
she's a road girl in it so she's on a
mountain yeah you get me so she's like
i don't know sunny i like that's her
name let's call her she's like she's
like [ __ ] what about you
and then she starts putting it on you i
just give her a strong back hand like a
peggy mitchell eastenders
like a [ __ ] backhand called a fence
you would call the fence wouldn't you
yeah
you would call the feds you work with
the feds you call the feds yeah
so let me ask you this though this leads
into my next question here so i do a
matting
yeah you do a mad scene i do a matching
yeah
the feds come and get me oh you do okay
i was like
right okay the fed's come not in zesty
in it not in zesty in that yeah i do a
mounting the feds come and get me yeah
they kick down your door they take me
it's like my thing like you're like yo
what's going on here
i'm about to do 10 years with the men
them up in their breath they want to
take my party it's mad and i'm a good
looking do i have to be one of those
prison wives that keeps like visiting
you and being like oh and then i have to
write you letters exactly will you hold
it down i don't know if i'm about that
he wouldn't hold it down well i don't
know i don't want to be one of those
prison women you know those girls who
date like
guys who are in prison and then they're
writing them letters like so then how
soon after
are you on another willy after i've been
locked up after they put me there how
long have we been together at this point
it's been a year again that's enough
time
that's still quite a long time to be
with someone i don't think i'm gonna
like jump on someone's straight away how
long now what's the estimate three to
five business days thing what is it what
are we talking about international
things two weeks no i take my time i
think when i usually like if i if a
relationship ends for me i take a good
month month and a bit
until until i sleep with someone else
yeah i'm not like jumping in straight
away with someone you're not going to
write me letters or nothing
i mean why did you go into what what
because i did a matching was it like
drug dealing or something no i literally
had to clap man's whole face off i mean
he's no longer here rev r.i.p to him and
everybody in his bloodline he's gone you
never see man again he's a ghost
with a murderer i don't know
but wouldn't you find that a bit sexy
though the fact that i didn't clap man's
head like a ted bundy sort of thing man
got rude and i had to clap his face off
bro went over to his yard clapped off
everybody like the whole family tree had
to go
i had to wipe off everything there's
nothing left how could i bring a
murderer home to my mum and dad wouldn't
excite you know you wouldn't at the
corner of your mind like yo he's a bit
sexy a bit dangerous
not not really never okay if you like i
don't know if you just sort of like
rough someone up a little bit okay maybe
that's a bit of a turn on maybe but not
like full-on murder no i rate you for
being honest you got me i rate you for
being honest yeah
yeah let's let's change the topic
that was getting a bit different it was
getting deeper yeah yeah
how freaky are you
i am quite kinky i like handcuffs and
things like that yeah i look a little
bit kinky but not like
you know i won't wear like a [ __ ] mask
or something you like whipping men out
you can whip me like with a spanking
paddle like a paddle
you can get these like puzzles right and
they have little like air holes in them
so then if you spank me it will leave
like a little mark which is quite i
think that's quite hard it's a bit zesty
still about absolutely yeah i must have
been a thing in central town toilets
once
in what tinsel town in in what's it
ferrendon you know fahrenheit oh yeah
yeah
it's like we literally went on a date
and in the moment this quarter she was
like come with me come with me i was
like oh where are we going i was like oh
where are we going yeah so do you say do
you say you do really well on dates then
that women just like have to have sex
with you straight away she was
salivating i could see in her face she
wanted the main event i could see it i
could see i could see all of her face i
knew it but then when she took she took
me to
she's taking me to the bathroom then she
takes me to the ladies toilet and i said
oh god now i'm going to be on a register
right what's what's going on i want to
be there i think man called committee
you're saying that it's a big man oh
yeah okay have you ever slept with a
celebrity a famous person no i've never
slept with a famous person i'm surprised
you know you're surprised
you're a beautiful woman i thought you
got me in your instagram would be
popping footballers i haven't no i've
had like
some fame famous people slide in the dms
but i haven't like gone out and like
slept with them or anything because also
it's like i don't want to date someone
just because they're famous like they're
kind of famous what like like gus from
eastenders in there
someone from eastenders actually did
slide
from eastenders
he was like the dad and he wore like the
jacket and he had like the hair keith no
i do not remember that at all keith how
about trevor remember trevor for me i
remember trevor yeah the the wife the
the beast
the wife was a mad guy right yeah
he was very mad no he he hasn't slid in
yet what like an extra like winston it
wasn't the random black button no it
wasn't extra it was somebody who's
actually like has had like a long
running part on eastenders and stuff
yeah shout out to phil brown
[Laughter]
shout out to phil i saw him one time in
elin
phil mitchell's not really my type so no
you don't like the bald look no my dad's
bald my dad's balls doesn't i'd be like
can your dad matting i don't know all
about it we don't condone that here but
on the on the
cloud chaser show but we don't condone
that again we went on that
i'm really looking for love i'm really
looking for that special it's a good
place to be yeah how about you when was
your last relationship it was literally
just before the pandemic started so
march 2020 it ended and then since then
i've been single so so why why did it
end
well you know what we just wanted
different things like
we kind of got together very quickly
um and then we ended up just yeah
wanting different things like i do
stand-up comedy and he does he does
comedy as well and i think there was
this sort of like competitiveness
between us and it just didn't really
work so yeah
you do stand up comedy so you're a funny
person yeah tell me a joke you're gonna
make me laugh i mean most of my jokes
are quite inappropriate like dick jokes
and like okay
i like dating jokes
so one guy said to me he said um are you
a new year's resolution
because i plan on doing you for the
first few weeks of january and then
forgetting about you for the rest of
2020
that's one challenge
yeah and that did actually happen to me
as well for real yeah so that was great
so you got the number and you just got
it and then you just went yeah i was a
new year's resolution basically so i
want you to tell me if if you like my
joke you're really funny you could would
you do stand-up comedy no why because
life ain't that funny but life is a mad
thing for me right now to be fair though
most of the things that are funny in
stand-up is like you moaning about life
anyway
i've got two jokes yeah all right one of
them somebody told me and he used to
make me bust up but it's a bit of a mad
one yeah and the other one is a joke
that i would tell so i got a funny joke
that i would say to to people and we
like to mend them like
like your dick's so small you pee on
your own balls beth
that's that's that's dope that's jokes
don't it yeah you're messing up you like
that
i mean it's quite silly it's very
similar it's very silly
but then this is the joke somebody told
me it was told to me by a guy in college
yeah he was a grunger
you know what grunges are a grunt what
like grunges in like grungy he's like a
graphic guy a gothic guy yeah he used to
have long hair
like he was kind of he kind of gave me
like unabomber vibes i'm not gonna lie i
felt he was gonna rap off the whole
school i was very afraid of him that's
why i befriended him because i thought
if he was going to go and lock off the
whole thing breath he would remember his
one black veteran and be like yo
and then save me brother and everybody
else would be gone right right just a
quick story about him i went on his
facebook the other day yeah yeah and
he's on some edl it's a mention
what does that even stop tommy morris
robinson and then man there he's one of
them man he shaved his gothic hair okay
right
racist brothers i couldn't even write
that
okay he's now a racist goth man but this
is the joke that he told me he said yeah
why did the girl fall off the swing
why did the girl fall
because she had no arms
that's a bit mad that's an awful child
yeah that's because that i should have
clocked that he was a sick youth from
back then
yeah no that's a bad joke that's a bad
yes but he's shout out to him i don't
know what he's going through brother but
black lives matter don't be moving
yeah what are you what are you thinking
about black people now i'm just joking
i'm taking them
obviously but i'm not very good at
naming songs there's some worries uh
what's the what's the song i don't even
know about you tell me you know them
people when you say i know that's yeah i
know about him storms here do you like
his rap music i just can't name the song
if stormzy came in right now brother and
he started splashing out cash and all
that stuff he just put out a wreck of
money pulled that in the range outside
got the big yard all of that and he came
out started flashing his money would he
be able to steal you from me
um
not no i'm not really impressed by
someone just throwing money up in the
air he's got the big boy rolly though
the rollie is mad yeah diamonds in there
i don't like when guys do that though
the whole like rolex thing but then he
pulls out their keys it's like an audi
r8 it's got the futuristic thing for the
year 3033 to ship flights
yeah no it caused me nothing to me at
all no no but i mean
he he's a good-looking guy though he's
hot like i would i would think he was
very attractive but i wouldn't be
tempted because he was showing me his
rolex in his fancy car because i know a
lot of that's just a materialistic thing
i know a lot of yellow i like that
they'll give up the non-bread quick you
just gotta be like yo rolly and then
that's it well girls do this thing like
i actually did a sketch about it right
where we're on a date
say i have my phone at the table where
i'll take a picture but i just won't get
your face in i'll get them watching oh
and then they'll put it on their story
and be like date night don't they girls
do that girls do that all the time and
it's a bit yeah girl are going dubai and
getting weed on bev it's cementing
full weed in their face meth a bit okay
yeah so miguel i'm moving mad out here
for the money that's why i'm on this
thing trying to find out if it's level
money yeah i think yeah so is that why
you're on this show basically that's
right trying to find out to find
the right woman right okay but i gotta
ask you this yeah so like
we're here together i'm looking at you
you're looking at me i could tell you my
favorite feature about you yeah i
thought i actually i'm looking at you
right but your sunglasses so dark i
cannot see your eyes
eyes are the window to the side it's a
lot of dangerous stuff
why are you wearing sunglasses though
and we're inside
i'm protecting myself from the demons
the frequencies
i can't let people into my soul
otherwise they take it away okay next
thing i'll be out here on on bricks and
high street selling reggae cds and
incense i lose my mind okay i can't do
that that's why but you're my favorite
features on you i love you got beautiful
and beautiful eyes oh thank you eyes a
lot of people say my eyes are my best
yes it was very like piercing i like
that stuff so would you break up with a
guy if his sex was dead probably yeah
how much leeway did you give him like
first time second time you're like
brother should be fair when you lose two
inches when you have sex with someone
the first time it sometimes isn't going
to be amazing just because you don't
sometimes you don't know what each other
like like what you you're both into so i
could you can let that slide yeah but if
it's gone to like
i know you've had sex five times and
it's still not there i feel like you
need to communicate it with them what's
your pet peeve with your insects
a pet peeve like what's something a guy
does like this gives you the egg not
even jiren saying what gives you the ick
okay i don't mind dirty talk that's fine
but i don't like when people like like
whisper it in your ear
just like it's been like really softly
like a soft whisper i wanted some night
stalker thing like just a soft whistle i
had a guided to me once when he like was
softly whispered in my ear and i was
like
weird
but i don't mind i don't know dirty talk
but it just has to be like vocalized
loudly not like whispered in my ears
talk how soon do you get into the dirty
talk i don't think on the first
i don't not on the first time you have
sex i think you should build yeah i
think you should you can't be calling
someone like a dirty [ __ ] like first
time you've had sex you're gonna let
right
someone on instagram he he called me a
slapper on instagram he slid into my dms
he called me slapper what's what's
what's what's his instagram so we could
tell him to suck his mum better
disrespect
now we don't do them things but i just
think that's such an old school word as
well would you call a girl slapper
that's such like that's though
eastenders isn't it what does that mean
though like a slap on a slap is like a
saga
it's like a dirty guy
yeah no no no no it's just such an old
word i don't really i don't really
insult women and stuff like that i think
it's a bit mad i can't argue with
guillermo then it's like i feel like if
i'm doing that then i got next thing i
got to be on rupaul's drag race brother
forget me like it's gonna be a bit
what's like your limits for the guy like
how much does a guy have to be earning
to date you hmm here's the thing i
wouldn't ask that on a date though i
wouldn't on a first date be like right
how much are you earning
because it's just such like isn't it so
materialistic but you got to know that
because what if like you get with man
he's like yo you meet in a club you've
seen rollies bottles all of that and the
next day's like yo babies i'm gonna
quickly head to job center to get that
universal credit what happened i've been
out with a lot of poor guys though a lot
of poor men and it hasn't like what's
your definition of poodle like what you
can't you got it
inside out
this was really stupid this is where i i
drew the line personally like we'd been
dating for a little bit and then he was
like oh i can't i can't come and see you
today because like i can't afford my
petrol
to get to
very much bearing in mind he only lived
like 20 minutes
and i was like no you could have walked
back he could have i would have been a
disciple for the nine bread i would have
literally been like yo let me do it you
would have got on the bike now i walked
it you get me quick little brisk
essential walks in that again you've got
to do what you've got i've traveled i've
traveled many lengths and far and very
far places i've traveled for the day how
far have you traveled for the day
i mean definitely out out of the m25
yeah what are we talking about the m25
to get to the dude where's that like
slow
slow flower's a mad policeman like it's
got to be within reach so how far did
you travel though like if we had to give
a cities like birmingham
i've been to birmingham yeah i don't
need a guy in birmingham
yeah well actually one of my
ex-boyfriends he lived at milton keynes
so is that how far you traveled for the
for the william for the day yeah i
traveled all the way to portsmouth for
some months for some nine bread
was it worth the journey um to be fair
it was you know because she ended up
being like a stripper it was just a bit
awkward because when we went out batman
was watching her and i was like oh my
god how do you know these were these
your neighbors in that night well surely
right if you're looking for someone
who's like not obsessed with money and
it's just like all about you and in love
with you surely in a way it might be a
good thing to date someone like a
stripper because they're earning their
own money they're not like after you for
like
you know that means bare men have seen
my girl's name brother it's kind of a
weird feeling bev like you get me like
imagine man just coming up to me
chanting me i'm with my girl and they're
just looking up and i'm like i've seen
everything but i've seen it in hdb
seen that [ __ ] in 4k bev give me another
example of what you mean by like broke
to be fair i have a lot of friends there
who are on like universal credit stuff
like that because when you're like
creative like sometimes you're just out
of work and you have to be you know so
then what if he's like your base like
he's on the universal credit thing he's
like yo babes i'm literally just the
eighth mixtape it's about to blow it's
just dreams and dreams and nightmares
volume 25 like this is gonna be the one
you've been with him from street dreams
volume one now street james
he's like babes this is gonna be the one
yeah and you're like
you're gonna wait with him until he
blows up i think it's good that he has
passion for something that he's got
passion for his music and whatever
and yeah i probably would stay with him
but if it's like oh yeah i'm working on
my music but then in the evening yeah
i'm
you know getting high and whatever it's
like okay well you're not really
committing to your work would you think
if his music's dead
would you be honest and be like babies
quite hard to support yeah so would you
go up to me like let's let's call a
spade a spade like your mixtape's dead
like what are we saying
would you tell him that would you be
real with him i feel like you should be
honest with with people i don't think i
could be with someone and just be like
oh my god yeah your music's so cool and
then in my head i'm thinking oh my god
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] so so you tell him to
his face and crush a song i think i
would say but i wouldn't say it like
that i wouldn't say oh your music's dead
how would you say how would you i would
like you know a soft blow like not my
wife then he says like babies you know
the music was keeping me going i'm going
to jump in front of this train now you
just ruined my life
but then i wouldn't want to be with
someone that insecure who's going to
like just suddenly go jump off the
bridge because i've said their music's
bad big man thing i like that i like
that right that's that's support right
there have you ever supported a man for
his hard times
what with money yeah no because i'm a
creative i've got no money myself
together
how can i help someone else
how could a man with no money charm you
know
you can do a cute picnic or something
like that that's not good
it costs a lot of money so you wouldn't
judge him no i think that's cute i think
that's not if you put a lot of effort in
and thought into it i think that's quite
sweet so what like one two blossom hill
it was quite a nice little day i think
what happens after that he's like yo
baby you've got to jump on the bus now
we've got to jump on the e7 what are you
saying boss is five i don't mind getting
on the bus i like that you see you're
right on buses it's fine you're a real
one for that little girl wouldn't do
that they'd be like rev [ __ ] you in your
petrol station sandwich beverly it's
dead evan christine what would you do if
on the day you lot in the park yeah and
they met him come up to him like you'll
[ __ ] you'll move beth idiot
and he's like oh [ __ ] i'm sorry i have
to what would you do then i do like a
guy who's going to stand their ground
and not be like oh my god i'm so sorry
like no he's gone why should he move
have they mash him up then what are you
saying are you going to back him
and he's like no no i will not move i
will not
no and he's like well the okay next
thing you see bear man stepping on him
turning the man into tomato puree rather
than just stepping on him
if i was with a guy right and if someone
approached him and he looked like he was
gonna attack him i would say to the guy
i'm with like okay let's just move like
i wouldn't want to cause a conflict what
would you do if he started being fully
released like yeah you want some you
want some stars taking off his clothes
no that's embarrassing
no he's backing himself no we're not
taking off their clothes and being like
oh yeah you want some no it's
embarrassing like handle things with
dignity walk away and be like all right
mate i'm going to move one thing is a
[ __ ] on no no i don't think he's a
[ __ ] for that so then if he gets mashed
up yeah and then you go home you're
going to give him the naan bread after
he's just been beaten up i got a mashup
he's like babes babes and they're like
shut up and he's weighing them in bro
just on some medicine there's busting
that up and he's back he's back at home
now he might not be capable to have sex
after that though if he's just been
beaten up but what if he wanted to know
and he's like babies i just want some of
that you're going to be like fam you've
got a bunch i just like give them a hug
or something make a cup of tea
for that that's good
that's a nice thing to do nice things to
do yeah i love that see now i'm here to
find the right woman i want to find the
right gal what makes you loyal
i think what makes me
loyal
is that say we've been on a few dates
already and we've already built like a
little connection between us why would i
then ditch you to just go with someone
who's got money i don't know anything
about that person
i don't know
what they you know i don't know anything
about them all i know is that they've
got a nice rolex and a nice car like
that doesn't make a person nice or like
wanna i want to spend the rest of my
life with them does it so yeah i think
that that's what makes me loyal anyway
so you wouldn't give them the nun bread
and a little quick one-night thing and
come back to me
[Applause]
no
no not just based on the fact that they
have a nice watch well they're trying to
fly you out more deeves than that i
would love to go to the maldives to be
fair
but i wouldn't sleep with someone
so i've had a great day it's been a
great time with you getting to know you
and all of that have you felt about this
date i've had a lot of fun it's been
good yeah i feel like we've we've got a
little vibe we've connected we've gotten
a deeper level with things a little bit
yeah i've had fun so now yeah you know
i'm trying to find true love show is
called clout chasers yeah so if i was to
choose you
could i rely on you yeah 100 i think
we've built like i said i think we've
built a bit of a connection
i feel i've been very honest with you
about like what i'm
after and like where i am where i'm at
in life so yeah what are your traumas
there's a lot you get me yeah if i take
these shades off this whole room will
get dark oh look yeah you know what this
is about yeah you're gonna give me a
ring
a ring
so what like like an onion ring thing
like like i would like to have
a strong black man that is emotionally
mature
and willing to work on these traumas and
grow from within
that's like free men rev that's smell
you just
you